between the convoluted lore cut content
and sometimes hilarious sometimes
annoying sometimes game breaking bugs
and bright atmosphere five nights at
freddy's security breach wasn't taken
quite as seriously by the community as
the previous titles were that's not to
say it wasn't a ton of fun to play and
get into of course and just because the
lore was a bit confusing doesn't mean it
wasn't still extremely interesting so
interesting in fact that i just had to
share my own two cents worth when it
came to a couple of theories and
wouldn't you know it i actually had an
extremely similar theory to mr matpat
himself who was gracious enough to
descend from the theorist heaven above
the clouds where he resides to invite
little old me onto his finaf theory
stream still reeling from that one and
let me just geek out for one second
about him it was seriously awesome
interacting with matpat not only was he
the one who reached out to me personally
on twitter but he also personally
introduced me to his staff and hopped
onto the stream for a full hour before
we went live just to chat with us no
matter what you think about his theories
he really is a swell guy and much nicer
and more approachable than i ever would
have thought given his position but
anyway i haven't returned to the series
for another theory since that stream
this is because frankly i felt that
between myself matpat super horror bro
doco fanaf and several others the game
had been pretty much covered but then
just over a week ago steel wool studios
dropped a major bomb on twitter as i'm
sure many of you know they posted a
picture that revealed the first official
story dlc for security breach named ruin
set to release in 2023 for free praise
steel wolf studios praise them but the
picture itself depicts the main lobby of
the mega pizza plex in a strange state
of well ruin this is quite different
from what we can see of this exact same
location in the game of course and as
such has prompted pretty much all the
other theory channels out there to
analyze it now i've watched some of them
but i haven't watched all of the other
analyses so i apologize if some of this
will sound like repeated information but
i would like to take this opportunity to
analyze the dlc image thoroughly and
discuss a theory or two on what exactly
i think could have happened to make the
pizzaplex take on this aforementioned
ruinous appearance also i wanted to take
a moment to thank my discord mod and
good friend staying for helping out with
researching this theory wouldn't have
been possible without him first and
foremost what sticks out to us the most
is probably the little girl standing
front and center facing away from the
camera her shoes are super cool but
besides her super cool shoes the fact
that this is another child with a
flashlight pretty much all but confirms
the notion that this girl whoever it may
be is going to be the next protagonist
in the dlc this is further supported by
the tv screens we can see hanging above
the ground that each seem to depict
gregory identifiable by his signature
polo and band-aid cheek in some sort of
distress even blurring his image by
presumably running past the camera in
some of the screens presumably running
away from you know death in front of the
girl is that giant golden statue of glam
rock freddy that previously was in great
shape in front of the lobby of the
pizzaplex but now it's quite broken with
the head lying to the side and the only
thing still standing being freddie's leg
at least i hope that's his leg to the
immediate left of the golden freddy
statue is a familiar face glamrock chica
who's looking quite a bit more damaged
than we previously saw i mean yeah we
broke her but we didn't break her that
much now she's missing that little
feather tuft on top of her head and also
most of her head besides horizon may be
beak one of her arms is half gone and
the other has no plating behind chica we
can see the familiar stairs of the lobby
complete with those iconic palm trees
but the stair railings have been broken
somehow at the top of the stairs the
elevators have been closed off by the
sliding garage doors that are used
elsewhere in the pizzaplex and the same
is true on the other side behind the
girl so closest to our viewpoint in this
image is a bunch of rubble scattered on
the ground since this definitely looks
like broken building material and it's
pink and it's lying between the statue
in the front of the pizza plex that
means it must have come from the pink
walls of the pizza plex beside the gift
shop and lost and found here on the
ground floor this implies that the walls
of the pizza plex are pretty heavily
damaged as we can even see some cabling
loose in the rubble that must have come
from inside the walls now you might
think that's all there is to this image
but there's actually one more detail i'd
like to point out and it's probably the
most important one of them all there are
dimly lit red eyes looking down upon the
area that we can barely see up in the
top left of the image they seem to be
hovering way above the ground implying
that this is either an entity that can
climb or one that's very big or both of
course these eyes aren't present
anywhere else which means that this
wasn't put in the image as just some
sort of atmospheric effect and as any
finaf fan worth their salt knows small
details are oftentimes the biggest i
think that steelwool wants us to know
that specifically and deliberately
there's an unknown entity lurking in the
dark waiting for us in the dlc and with
that i'm pretty sure that covers every
detail from the dlc reveal image now
let's get down to the theories and try
to answer what the hell is going on here
the first theory that i'll bring up is
the simplest and most boring but
unfortunately is decently probable and
as such i shall cover it here it's
possible that the only difference
between security breach and security
reach ruin is the passage of time this
doesn't explain gregory's predicament or
the appearance of the girl of course but
it could explain the broken down
appearance of pretty much everything in
the picture especially after it all
allegedly burns down after the burn trap
ending but that depends on which ending
is canon of course okay cool that wraps
up theory number one put it in the back
of your mind because now let's talk
about a much more interesting but also a
tad bit wackier theory remember how
gregory is shown running around in those
security monitors possibly asking us to
help him considering the fact that
gregory is clearly still alive and the
same age as he was in the original game
i tend to think that this means there
actually hasn't been all that much of a
time passage since the events of the
game some people have mentioned that
gregory could have gotten scanned into
the system at some point which would
mean that he remains the same age while
time passes indefinitely which is
definitely possible we all know that's
far from the first time that human
consciousness is being scanned into data
has happened in the series but the
reason that i don't buy that just yet is
that he's shown running around actual
rooms in the pizzaplex some of which i
can even identify in the screens where
it's looking at his face and he's
glancing to the right you can see
circular lights in the ceiling above him
and stars on the wall behind him some
small and some big this doesn't match up
picture perfectly but it really seems
like this is one of the green rooms of
the glamrock cast complete with the
circle ceiling lights and the star
mirrors since it doesn't 100 match up it
doesn't concretely disprove that he
could still be running around a data
world but it makes it less likely that
that's the case because this isn't the
only room he's shown running through and
more likely that he's simply running
around the inside of the pizzaplex
trapped inside and this is why we can
see those closed garage doors over the
elevators they're closed to keep gregory
inside and prevent him from escaping and
i actually think this alludes to a
gameplay element of the dlc where we may
have to help guide gregory out of the
pizza plex safely using the security
cameras in classic finaf style while he
and ourselves are avoiding dangerous
animatronics at all costs but back to
the theory though at the same time even
though there might not have been much of
a passage of time there is still all
this you know ruin lying around and all
of this rubble around the place is very
telling so telling that the entire dlc
is going to be named after it the point
is if time didn't cause all this ruin
that means that something or someone
else did and honestly that kind of makes
sense given the broken and torn apart
state of the golden freddy statue with
the giant hole in the chest which
doesn't happen to gold given the passage
of time and the straight up puncture
holes in the stair railing and the pink
rubble that must have flown a good 10 to
15 feet to land here so here's the
question who or what is responsible for
all of this was it chica maybe i don't
know she gets angry sometimes but i
think that's where this mysterious
red-eyed entity comes in and by the way
i just want to throw this out there i
doubt this entity is fanny because there
are no pupils she always has pupils also
it's way above the ground and last i
checked vanie isn't spider-man as
horrifying of a notion as that is
instead we've got to ask ourselves if
there are any animatronic monsters in
the game that could inflict this kind of
damage to structures and giant statues
could potentially crawl on walls and
that sport glowing red eyes and once we
search with this criteria we're actually
left with a few possibilities in the
first place it could be the daycare
attendant specifically when he goes
crazy and turns into moon and is limber
enough to crawl around on the walls with
glowing red eyes he's still running
around the place by the end of security
breach so i guess it's possible although
i feel like this particular animatronic
wouldn't be strong enough to inflict all
this damage and he's also infamously
obsessed with keeping everything in
order not chaos so let's move on the
next possibility would be one or several
of the endoskeletons which each feature
glowing red eyes i could see a lot of
them running around the place breaking
stuff but if this were the case you
would think that there would be multiple
pairs of red eyes in the image instead
of the single pair that we see which
definitely is supposed to imply a single
entity the final possibility and most
likely in my opinion would be the
massive heap of animatronic innards the
blob see no matter what ending you play
through in security breach the blob
exists and nobody has come up with a
good answer as to why it exists but no
matter what we know that at the time of
the dlc the blob has to still be alive
somewhere in the pizzaplex even when
completing the burn trap ending we
specifically don't see the blob die
actually the opposite it looks like it
snatches a burn trap and then retreats
presumably to safety if its fate was to
burn to death you'd think they'd show us
that in a cinematic the blob was such a
strange but extremely important addition
to the cast of security breach because
it's just there underneath the pizza
plex for some reason and it includes
lots of the bodies of the original five
nets at freddy's cast though we're still
not sure how they got there besides wild
speculation i think someone put them
there but that's just me and wouldn't
you know it the blob just so happens to
feature glowing red eyes on its
preferred funtime freddy face now we
don't know which ending to the game was
canon but let's assume for a moment that
the only ending where you see the blob
and fight the big baddie of the entire
franchise billy afton himself is the
canon ending as everything is burning
around you and gregory and glamrock
freddy are running away to safety burn
trap is snatched up by the blob this has
a lot of implications if it snatched him
up because it was trying to kill him
that doesn't make too much sense because
it could have just let him burn i mean
who knows maybe the fourth time's the
charm but if it was trying to save him
which seems more likely then the
question is why perhaps the blob
mindlessly snatched up burn trap because
it saw another remnant filled living
animatronic and wanted to integrate it
into its growing blob body i mean just
look at the thing that's apparently
something that's made a habit of doing
quite a lot of that's kind of the whole
point of its appearance as a blob and i
dare say that might even be what it
tries to do to gregory if it catches him
in the fight and if you look closely in
the cutscene the blob seems to just kind
of peek into the room to see what's
going on then reacts to burn trap like
it's just now noticing him before
grabbing him up but what if when it did
that burn trap slash glitch trap william
afton took over the blob itself he is a
virus after all and he is in desperate
need of a body meaning the blob could be
none other than william afton but i'm
not done yet the blob may be big and it
may have red eyes but it's still just a
blob kind of formless made of tentacles
the blob itself would probably need some
sort of endoskeleton or animatronic body
to take control of in order to move
around and inflict the damage we see in
the dlc screen but there isn't one
around that's big enough for all that
blobber right actually there is i know
this sounds crazy but listen it could
explain some of the random things we saw
in the game remember that when you drop
down to go beneath the pizza plex and
enter the old finaf6 pizzeria where the
blob is if you look to the left after
exiting the elevator you see a random
giant freddy head and claw again this
being here is just as unexplained as the
blob being here but yet both of them are
of great importance and have strong ties
to the original members of the franchise
you can even see the giant freddy head
in cinematic glory when gregory and gr
blah when gregory and glam rock freddie
are running out of the pizzaplex so it
must be important if they went through
all the trouble of rendering it even
after all their budget and content cuts
so my dear watchers what if the red-eyed
giant blob which may or may not include
burn trap possesses the giant freddy
animatronic hidden beneath the pizzaplex
and proceeds to wreak havoc and ruin the
mega pizzaplex the only thing this
doesn't explain is why gregory has
apparently returned to the pizzaplex and
is now trapped inside but i'd just like
to remind everyone real quick that no
matter what ending the blob and the
giant freddy blobby if you will exists
in every ending regardless and i don't
think we can explain why gregory would
return to the pizzaplex presently
especially since all of the endings of
security breach end with gregory
escaping except for one where he escapes
and then vani finds him anything gregory
could do after escaping is completely
speculative i think there are simply
some other details that have yet to be
revealed to the public that will shed
light on both that and who the girl in
the picture is i mean gregory is said to
not have any family so maybe he met this
girl while he was out of the pizza plex
and then glamrock freddie who might
still be connected wirelessly to the
pizzaplex system sensed blobby walking
around and told him something was wrong
and that he needed to return or
something and so gregory went off to
return but then didn't come back and so
this new girl space friend has now come
looking for him that's a hundred percent
speculative though this theory also
doesn't explain what's happening with
vani or vanessa but that's another
subject that once again could change
drastically depending on which ending is
canon hey maybe both the vani ending and
the burn trap ending are canon somehow
but as far as the new villain of ruin
and what happened to the pizzaplex in
the dlc goes i think this is a pretty
decent guess but that's just my theory
though what do you guys think is the
pizza plex all run down because it's
been like a thousand years and gregory
is trapped in a digital world or is the
mysterious red-eyed blob the one hunting
down gregory potentially in a giant
freddy suit potentially containing burn
trap let me know in the comments below
and thank you so much for watching
please leave a like on the video if you
enjoyed it or at least my efforts into
making it and subscribe if you haven't
already because i'm going to cover your
favorite video game franchise inevitably
huge thanks as always to my banny crew
who are the reason i can continue making
these geeky videos for all of you to
enjoy that's all i've got for this one
so i hope you have a wonderful rest of
your day this is bandit looking forward
to seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you